blac chyna was involved in a scary car  crash in LA like what  [Music]  China was rear-ended by another vehicle  in Studio City California  around 2:30 early Saturday morning  according to TMZ paramedics later  assessed the 29 year old star in the  back of an ambulance before she was  released and picked up by another car  we're all in a good place an LAPD  officer reportedly detained the other  driver and administrated a DUI test at  the scene the mom of two was driving her  $400,000 Rolls Royce at the time of the  accident a gift  Rob Kardashian gave her as a push  present after welcoming their daughter  dream  I'm obviously more than willing to do  whatever it takes for China  you